u.s 95 from horizon to boulder highway
is closed in each direction after a
shooting on the roadway good evening and
thank you for joining us tonight at five
o'clock i'm sasha loftis this happened
around 12 30 this afternoon on the
highway henderson police say the suspect
is on the run tonight right now traffic
is backed up as many are heading back
from lake mead in willow beach madison
kimbrough joins us live near the scene
tonight with the latest madison
according to henderson police at least
one person was shot right here on
highway 95 when we were driving
southbound we saw several police cars
and motorcycles stopped off the side of
the road right now henderson police have
confirmed the suspect is still on the
run we also know there is at least one
victim but it's still unclear if they
were taken to the hospital as for other
closures horizon drive from pacific to
highway 95 is also closed in both
directions as the scene here continues
to be active there is a detour in place
at wagon wheel drive to boulder highway
that's exit 17 so if you are in the area
make sure to be careful and take your
time reporting live in henderson madison
kimbrough live local now